[Music]
how's it going everyone we are live here
talking about google summer of code 2022
with the julia language i'm super lucky
that we have two folks here to with us
to help answer questions and we'll
definitely be taking questions as uh as
this live stream goes on we're gonna
kick off with just hearing about uh luca
and anant's experience doing google
summer of code with the julia language
and then
again as folks have questions feel free
to toss those into the chat and we'll be
we'll be monitoring those so we we
already have a bunch of people uh
joining us and being part of the stream
so thanks everyone for being here um
luca do you want to get started and just
talk about uh when you did google summer
of code the the project you worked on
suggestions as far as the application
experience things like that
yeah yeah sure so
hi i am luca ferranti and i participated
in google summer of code the last year
in 2021
for my project i did it well in the
language and particularly in the julia
intervals suborganization of julia if
you want
and i developed this interval in algebra
gl package during the program
and yeah yeah of course the experience
was very good otherwise i wouldn't be
here today and regarding the application
i think the most important part is like
discuss before i had with your mentor
and
ask feedback about that
and
actually
don't spend too much time writing the
application so let your code and your
practice speak for yourself so the
application shouldn't take too much time
like i don't know one two hours or
shouldn't be too long at least just uh
get in touch with people get started
open issues open pull requests comment
be active on repositories on coding
github and let your open source activity
speak for yourself that's like the best
for the application
yeah i hope it's helpful and have glad
to ask any other questions
yeah luke i love that we'll we'll dive
in and talk more talk more specifics um
but announce i know you're maybe having
connection trouble do you want to give
us a quick intro and when you
participate in google summer of code
what your project was that kind of stuff
yeah sure um i think my internet issues
are mostly fixed now
so i'm ananth i'm one undergrad uh in my
final year
uh majoring in computer science from
bangalore india and uh i was also a gsoc
student not a gsoc jsoc a gsoc student
with uh the julia language or the
organization or the ecosystem that i was
contributing to was camellia
i think on the jsoc page it's still
listed as deep kevin.gl but then we'll
update that soon enough and my project
was called tidebinding neural networks
uh which is basically implemented
implementing this idea called orbital
graph convolution neural networks
which is uh in layman's terms to say uh
so in convolution networks you usually
have more features as well in whatever
um
whatever object that you're trying to or
you know model
so that particular featurization you
also embed information about the atomic
orbitals of
the respective elements and respective
nodes in the given molecule so this is
my overarching uh project um
to an extent uh i got started on it um
i think
mostly it was focused on research side
of things at the same time the entire
ecosys entire chameleon ecosystem was
also undergoing a major refactor so i
also helped greatly contribute to that
um i was a g-sucker in last year the way
i got started was uh by getting started
with documentation i basically just cold
mailed my mantra saying that okay so
um i found this on the uh julia page and
i'm very interested in this i'd like to
get started on this and she said okay
the documentation is a great part
because we basically have none of it
right now
so uh documentation was a great way to
get started and a few months in after
contributing i sort of realized oh i
found this on the json page might as
well apply for g software like there's
no harm and and then i played and then i
got in and it was a great few months um
it was great exposure to the language
itself and especially i must say to the
community which has been which has been
an amazing experience so far
yeah i know i love that i think
um
i'm excited to see
folks
who have questions and really quickly
wanted to remind folks that if you if
you have questions uh please send them
in add them in the comments and that way
we can uh get luke and not to answer
those for us
but let's
let's kick off and and something that
i've been thinking a lot about recently
with respect to google summer of code is
the the whole sort of
mentor mentee process and like how like
what what did you two do when you were
reaching out um to prospective mentors
um like how did you approach that did
you just message them on slack or you
know were you doing code contributions
beforehand and then message them
afterwards or something like that can
you elaborate luca i'll start with you
about
what that process was like yeah uh
so actually before doing gsoc last year
also was in gsod the summer
season documentation the year before and
my mentor was the same so i guess the
more interesting question is how i
conducted the first time and yeah i
literally just showed up from the
internet i sent it he was he is like
david sanders and he's involved in this
julia intervals packages
and i just
sent him a message hi i
like
the topic i found it very interesting
and i see you have like this there's the
g-shot coming and it would be
interesting contributing and
participating are you planning to apply
as mentor we could develop so
yeah just a straight face sent him a
message he never heard of me before i
never heard of him before just
there and that's how it started so
it's
don't be scared that people in open
source don't bite and they're most of
the times like very very friendly so
just there to contact them
yeah no that's great i think there's a
there's a lot of power in just reaching
out to people uh randomly on the
internet and i think uh david is is
awesome and i think um probably having
him as your as your mentor for google
season of docs and then google summer of
code was was probably awesome he's he's
super great every time i've gotten a
chat with him um not you want to talk
about uh same thing about how you sort
of were able to reach out to folks uh
to be your mentor or ways that you
approach that that kind of stuff
you're still muted at the moment
okay i'm muted now 100 agree with what
luca is saying about open source people
not fighting
because um so
the way i approached my who became my
mentor was a bit unconventional um when
i approached her
she was rachel curtin she's a postdoc at
cmu
when i approached her i had uh like i
wasn't really planning on applying for g
sub jsoc any of that i just uh had
gotten started with julia then and i
actually want to get some real
experience contributing my actual
package because i felt that would make
me
help me learn the language much better
so um and then like i said uh after a
point we just realized okay i just found
this project from the project section on
the gsoc on the our website so might as
well apply for it right and she was more
than happy to be my mentor and yeah it
was a great
few months um and also the way i
approached her wasn't on slack or
anything at that point i i didn't even
really know that the julia lang slack
existed she was the one who told me that
there's something like this
so i just cold mailed her right on the
blue and she was kind not respond and
you know we sort of had conversations
going back and forth and then that's how
that works
yeah that's and and honestly rachel is
uh
another amazing mentor so i think you
you both probably hopefully had a great
experience because i think rachel and
david are both um are both awesome and
you know i think the the takeaway for
folks is
not from your from your um from your
comments is like there is a julia laying
slack that is where a lot of these
conversations take place we also have a
zulu channel um which is sort of the
open source alternative to slack you can
see all this stuff if you go to the
julia lang website under the community
tab there's all the different channels
where julia conversations and things
like that are happening
so i think we have this listed on the
uh
g-sock student guidelines now like what
you're supposed to do is join the jsoc
channel on slack and you know be part of
that conversation um so 100 would would
agree join the slack have those
conversations reach out to people and i
think again from from my perspective the
suggestion i'll give to folks is
the the mentors are really busy um you
know maintaining open source projects
doing their job answering other
questions from from students so try to
try to do as much as you can to sort of
take away the burden from uh the mentors
like you know
google as much stuff as you can look up
all like if your question is like what's
the timeline for google summer of code
like don't send that question to your
mentor go and you know google that
question uh try and find the answer
before you go and and you know try and
take your mentors direct time
to to have that question answered
um
this this is great though i think uh
we've got um our third panel member
saranjeet
joining us um sanji can you can you hear
me okay
yes i can hear you
wonderful how's it going
i'm good how are you so nice to be here
i'm doing great
saturday morning nothing nothing better
that i'd want to be doing than talking
about julia stuff um saranji you want to
give us a quick intro when you did uh
google summer of code or julia summer of
code um and any sort of uh and what your
project was
yes so i was a part of google summer of
code 2020 with the julia language
organization and i was working with the
turing team
at that time
uh i worked on a project to build uh
proposals for nested sampling algorithm
so yeah
it was g-sock 2020.
nice who can you um the the question
that lukan and i were just answering was
about any any specific um suggestions or
like how did you reach out to your
mentor any any suggestions for that as
far as like getting in contact with a
mentor
ways of engaging with them that sort of
stuff
uh
so i started uh
uh communicating with the potential
mentors through the
julia slack
so
the topic that i i put forth my idea
that i'm interested in this topic and i
was looking for mentors through the
slack and then there are really very
helpful people on the julia slack
that are
very supportive and
they they can guide you to the
person who can help you further so that
was
how i started
nice i love that um
i think let's i'm seeing i'm seeing at
least one question come in um from uh
ashwani asking
any any specific proposal related
guidelines
and i think i i can
generally answer this but also
interested to hear from all three of you
about how you all put together your
proposal but in general from the julia
languages side we do have specific
proposal guidelines they're on the
website
if you go to
the jsoc tab on the website and then you
go to the
there's an applications guidelines
section
and that has all of the specific
format stuff that we want and also the
specific pieces of the application that
we want you to answer so definitely
check that out um it's on the it's on
the website i can send the link in the
in the chat for folks um but interested
and
not if you're if you're here potentially
we'll start with you this time um
how did you go about doing your proposal
was there any any specific tips or
suggestions that you'd give
a g-shock student who's applying on how
to put together the best proposal
possible
really uh just one major tip that i have
um with respect to everything gsox
related is communicate with your mentor
because i feel like that's the most
important part of the entire process
that a lot of people
often overlook
so what i did was like i said um i
didn't really go into this with the
notion that i need to do g's hawk at
this point right just this is something
that came up
so um the way
we uh so regina and i had discussion
about what she would like to see done in
this ecosystem like uh what she thinks
of potential things that we should be
solving and potential things that we
need to be doing to enable the ecosystem
to be
richer and you know more full-fledged
thing
so uh we first had that conversation and
then uh like you said um i did a lot of
research um i came up with the draft
proposal of based off whatever
guidelines were on the website
and then um i i shared it with her you
know sort of gave her a preview of what
my proposal was going to be and she was
very helpful in that regard she gave a
lot of useful feedback i incorporated
those feedback and it's sort of a cycle
right so and sort of review and she
reviews it again
i incorporate more changes and that just
makes the proposal a lot more better so
i'd say uh one thing is communicate with
your mentor because that's the most
important thing um you know happy mentor
happy youth
because if your mentor is happy with
your project then even if it doesn't get
up except except for g software json
it's a great project right and that's
something you should be doing regardless
i know i love that i think happy happy
mentor happy you might be a tagline for
for gsoc in general like i think so much
of the the experience of gsoc depends on
your mentor and i think having a really
positive
uh sort of communication between you two
is is super important um saranjan any
anything you want to add on to
um proposal suggestions
uh yes so
uh the most important one is to get
feedback from the community slack so
once you have a draft ready you can
share it on the community slack and
there are people not just your mentor
but there are many other people who
would be happy to provide you a general
feedback on the structure
uh if if you if you also
want specific feedback then please feel
free to share it with your mentor as
well
uh
try to
try to uh
get some time
with your mentor where you are
discussing your proposal before actually
writing it so if you if you discuss it
well enough it will
always reduce the time that is required
in the future when you need to mold it
so
and yes
try to provide a timeline on your
proposal so that is also very helpful
yeah strategy i love that i think
especially getting feedback from the
community like i you know i don't want
to sign you three up to do work but like
there's tons of former gsoc students who
are in the different channels on slack
we have you know a bunch of gsoc alumni
who are now mentors and things like that
so people are really happy to help um so
posting your proposal in the slack
channel getting feedback uh from the
community i think can really be a super
important piece and another aspect of it
too is that the
like a huge part of of google summer of
code is being involved in the community
and i think it's a really good sign to
see
from a mentor's perspective hey this
person put the proposal in they got
community feedback about how to make it
better you know how it better aligns
with the communities like strategic
technical goals
things like that and i think it can
really bode well for um for students who
are applying if they do get that
feedback so i love that suranji um
luca you want to you want to add
anything else
yeah i i agree i can maybe add what i
briefly mentioned at the beginning that
don't
focus too much on the writing i think
also uh chris mentioned last year in
slack that you must open at least if you
pull a request to show the code so it's
really about coding and you don't need
to be like a super pro software engineer
at the beginning but you need to show
that you are not afraid of open pr's or
that
you understand that it's important to
document the code or to have unit tests
or this kind of stuff and
so uh get started it's pretty good in
open source you don't really need to ask
permission to start helping us you can
just open issues and open pr's and
ask for your mentor ask do you have like
an issues that would be like not too
challenging at the moment that they can
get done in reasonable time but not to
trivial that could show my skills that's
actually what i did with david he gave
me like i said said okay and this
package at the moment are like these
issues like dc code is very slow this
code is not working this is a battle
which is pretty annoying so
start with getting those fixed and then
you can show off in the proposals that
you actually are already involved in the
community and
they have like some code visualization
of what you have been doing so
don't start coding the night before
let's say let's start the helping and
yeah
yeah luca i love that and i i actually
think um i agree with you it's you know
in general for folks i think it's worth
saying that there's this there's this
tension in g-shock and and g-sock is
designed to help get students involved
in open source but then also mentors and
organizations a lot of time ask for
students to show some some evidence to
them that they know how to program and
they know how to contribute to open
source so it's it's weird that like you
know it's advertises this this avenue to
start contributing to open source but
then you show up as a contributor and
people are like oh we want you to
already have done some work before so
it's i i can understand from a student's
perspective that it's a little bit um
it's a little bit weird and it's a
little bit confusing but luca i totally
agree with you like
as much evidence as you can show in your
proposal that
you know how to contribute you know you
know you have some you know not
expertise but you have some ability to
actually make contributions that's going
to really help your proposal if you
don't have any code contributions
specific
it's probably unlikely that you'll get
selected for google summer of code
so it's it's worth thinking about how
you can you know start today make a few
of those contributions
it doesn't have to be anything super
another thing i'd like to add is that um
while community and usually mentors are
quick to give reviews on your um
on your proposals uh i don't think you
should expect it as a given from them
because
everyone is really busy and i mean you
should respect and be sensitive to that
as well so also don't be disheartened if
people aren't like commenting on your
proposals yet or something
no i totally agree that's that's a
totally fair point like your mentor may
not have the the bandwidth right now to
give you a review of the proposal before
google summer of code i think you should
make it available to them like i think
that's the biggest piece like if you
don't send it to them um and they do
have the bandwidth and then they're
reviewing it when the the application
actually comes in they're like wait a
second i never saw this before this is
completely new to me i think that could
be a problem so make it available to
them post it publicly on the on the jsoc
channel tag your mentor um to see if
they can have time to review it but yeah
definitely don't go in with the
expectation that they're gonna
spend five hours giving you feedback on
on your proposal i think that's a great
point
uh another another thing that you could
do is actually to
read through some of the previous
proposals that are already present
uh
that will also give you a rough idea to
how to begin writing the proposal
i know some there are some changes this
time but uh you can always refer to the
previous year proposals and get some
ideas
yeah suranji i don't know if we have any
of those proposals online but if you
three want to share um you can put them
on the julia website if you wanted to or
if you want to send them on slack if you
if you're comfortable sharing feel free
to um just to give folks sort of an
example of obviously successful google
summer of code applications since all
three of you um were chosen and selected
so feel free to do that um
yeah other folks who are listening feel
free to reach out you can see the the
list of google summer of code students
that were accepted in previous years
on the website so you can
reach out to those folks and ask to see
uh successful applications if you're if
you're interested in that as well
so mert's uh making a comment about uh
seeing other organizations example
proposals but we didn't see julius so i
mert i i would suggest you take a look
at
um the application guidelines link that
i sent and if that doesn't answer the
question um feel free to post in the in
the jsoc channel but i think that that
that link that i sent
does give you the right
um the right stuff to actually get the
application in so if if it's unclear
feel free to post again and we'll try to
get the questions answered for you
um another question will contributions
will the contributions projects on jsoc
be available out of gsoc for students
that want to contribute later yeah this
is i mean so
the
gsa and jsoc are just ways of of helping
um
get financial contributions to to
students to contributors um in general
who want to participate in open source
um so if you
have the bandwidth and time and you want
to just tackle a gsoc project without
being part of vsoc and and not getting
paid to do it then yeah that's totally
cool you're welcome to do that and i
think
something to keep in mind is um you know
doing stuff like that
can potentially be really helpful in
getting selected for gsoc in in future
years like a lot of people who are
unsuccessful the first time they apply
for gsoc they end up making some open
source contributions over the course of
the next year they applied the second
time around and they get selected so i
don't know if if any of you
went through that process but i've a
hundred percent met people who applied
the first time for google summer of code
didn't get in um made contributions came
back a second time and they got in after
making some open source contributions
yeah i don't know did all of you get in
on your first
your first
application yeah
awesome
so it can be either i mean i think
that's it's super positive it doesn't um
you might get accepted your first time
uh you might not and i think that's just
the the nature of it so going in with
the mentality that
you're there and i think i not you
mentioned this before but like going in
with the mentality that you're there to
contribute to open source it would be
great if you got selected for gsoc
because it's a it's a cool program but
really the goal is to contribute to open
source and it's going to whether or not
you're part of gsoc you're gonna get all
that benefit you're still gonna have
this you know proof of work you're gonna
be able to send in a job application and
show them that you made these open
source contributions things like that um
so yeah i i would i would go in with the
mentality that you're there to
contribute to open source not that
you're there to to be a part of google
summer of code necessarily um but a
great question nonetheless
um another question
considering your project is a
large-scale one 300 hours is there a
possibility that more than one person
will get selected for the project
this is a good question i think this is
a the the 300 hour versus the 175 hour
thing is new to gsoc this year i believe
last year uh we only had 175 hour
projects if i recall correctly and then
the year before that it was only 300
hour but they didn't really put the hour
number on it it was just like gsoc like
they do the project and there was no
hours specified um
so i i don't think that got that mentors
will be
splitting up 300 hour projects i think
it's it's specifically the reason they
have these different hour amounts is to
make gsoc more flexible for students so
if you're a student who knows that you
have other commitments this summer and
you don't have full-time
availability for 18 weeks or 16 weeks
whatever it is like that's why the 175
hour project exists so you can still be
a part of gsoc and do your summer school
class or and you know travel on vacation
for two weeks or whatever it is um so i
i don't think that we'll be splitting
the 300 hour projects between multiple
students if more than one person applies
so yeah hopefully
rb that answers the that answers the
question for you
um actually i'd like to quickly continue
so in the previous iterations of gsoc i
know that um there have been a few
projects for other organizations like
the um linux foundation and so on and so
forth
that um multiple students have worked on
the same project but then that has been
largely uh dependent on the students
itself or deciding to coordinate and the
mentor so it might be much harder but
then i think it largely depends on your
bandwidth and your mentor's bandwidth
and you finding someone who's willing to
do that
it's not a guarantee but
i mean mohammed trying right
yeah no i think that's a that's a good
point it's also possible depending like
the
the challenges for a mentor like if
you would almost if you did if one of
these projects was to be split up it
would have to be sort of coordinated in
advance like it's unlikely that
two people are going to apply with the
exact same proposal and the mentor is
just going to automatically be like okay
we'll just split this up between two
people if you took a larger project and
someone applied for
you know 175 hours of it and another
person did some other piece of it like
that could be the way that it's split up
but it's not i don't think that the
mentors are just going to do that
implicitly if two people apply for the
same project because again the reason
that the 300 versus 175 hours exists is
to give students flexibility so if
someone applies for 300 hours it means
that's how much time they have available
therefore that's how much time we should
give them to work on google summer of
code um
yeah so great great question another one
coming in
i'm asking this is i honestly do not
feel i have enough julian knowledge but
i have enough experience working in open
source code basis and contributions what
do you think so interesting to hear from
all three of you where where were you in
your
julia journey i guess um
is the best way to put it when you
applied for google summer of code did
you already have a bunch of
julia specific knowledge or was it
really like i had knowledge in python
and r and i was just getting started in
the julia community um so interested to
hear i think luca you were doing google
seasonal docs before so maybe you had
some julia knowledge already
uh yeah i had some
julia experience but it's actually fun
because every time i was getting started
i thought yeah i have enough to the
experience but then during the process i
realized oh actually i didn't have that
much experience and i learned a lot
during the journey so
i guess it's normal it's
you don't need a lot of or you don't
need much like julia specific like
coding
knowledge as long as you have some
experience that's very valuable then you
can learn during the process because you
don't need to know everything at the
very beginning you can learn during the
process
and so yeah i definitely wasn't expert
when i started
g-shock i wasn't expert when i slt
g-shot i don't know if i'm expert now
but every time i think
i have good experience then i interact
with new people and the chat on slack
and i learned a bunch of new cool things
and i was like oh there's actually a lot
i didn't know and so
that's every time i do julia stuff i'm
like wow there's actually a lot that i
don't know so i'm i'm with you
uh saranji where where were you in your
sort of julia uh journey when you
applied for a gsoc
so i was
more into r and python at that time
and not so much into julia i did i did
so most of the skills were transferable
so i was
learning to code and write those codes
for quite some time in julia but i would
not say that it was comparable to how
much i could do in r or python so when i
when i had applied uh
and when i came out of gsoc there was a
huge
learning
difference and the things that i learned
not just about julia but also about
contributing to open source
making
pull requests in a pull request in a
good manner uh
and collaborating using git so
it was a
very
uh steep learning journey for me
yeah so i i can say that i i started
from basic level uh with julia and when
i had applied for gsoc
yeah that's that's interesting insurance
do you
do you think anything specifically that
you did in your application like
helped or do you have any tips on like
if somebody's in the same position as
you maybe they've used other languages
they've made other contributions but
they haven't yet done that in the julia
context like how can you demonstrate
that you have the interest and the
ability to actually make those julia
contributions
yes so
when i had applied i uh mostly
highlighted the work in theory that i
had done so i had done quite a lot of
study in that area using r and i demos i
had
communicated this with my mentor that i
have worked with our previously on this
topic and now i want to move into julia
uh so that is where i started and i was
very open with my mentors that this is
where i stand uh with my
uh knowledge in julia
but yes with time uh
they were very supportive and with time
i kept on learning the concepts as they
came by
yes ranjit i actually think i remember
and this is maybe a good i remember your
application i think this might be a good
suggestion for other people as well too
like
if you don't have that
deep julia working knowledge like
highlight your deep knowledge of the
domain that you're working in like i
think you're sanjay you were doing like
nested sample or stuff i don't even know
what that means but highlighting like
the specific like theory and technical
understanding that you have of the
subject area can be really really
important as well um
yeah so i i love that comment uh not any
any suggestions you want to make on that
front
yeah um so as i've already said like a
bunch of times already so um i didn't
get started with um camellia for gsa i
just wanted to
get a feel of julia itself so camilla
was basically the first bit of korean
junior code that i wrote so i wanted to
learn the language actually working on
packages and it felt like this had the
lowest barrier of entry to me at least
as compared to flux and difficult and
the whole time ecosystem and all that at
that point
so um
yeah so i barely had any junior
knowledge at that point um i did have
experience with other programming
languages like cec plus plus javascript
python and all that but then this was
the first time that um i had experience
with julia and uh
yeah it turned out pretty great
i love that um
cool let's go to the next question
uh our bit asking 175 hour versus 300
hours is it something that should be
mentioned by the student or the mentor
so all of the projects on the google
on the julia website
under the google summer of code section
should have hours specified it should
already it should already say on the
project page whether it's 175 hours or
300 hours
so if it doesn't say for that project
definitely ask the mentor and reach out
um
because you you need to know that i
think when you actually do the
application you have to specify whether
it's a 175 hour or 300 hour
difference and i think uh
i bet you had another follow-up which
was your proposal may require more than
175 hours um
is it okay if you start working yes you
can start working before the gsoc period
the disclaimer is always that you could
start working and
we don't have any control over what
happens google could come back to us and
say um
you get one one google summer of code
slot this year like that's all you get
we have no control over it so i would
you can go in and start making
contributions but go in with the
knowledge that
um that doesn't mean that you're going
to get selected for google summer of
code and
you know we might not have the slot or
the funds to actually pay you to do that
development work hopefully we will um
especially if you're doing great work
and it's it's helpful and beneficial for
the community but we can't we can't
promise and guarantee that
that that that is actually going to
happen because it's so out of our
control with respect to google summer of
code
so hopefully that
is helpful and answers the question but
another piece here mert's asking uh does
making non-technical contributions help
uh you get selected for for google
summer of code for julia summer of code
i've got my opinions on this but
interested if anyone uh if anyone has
any thoughts
oh sorry
yeah i think non-technical contributions
are a great way to get noticed by mentor
and also to understand um what exactly
goes on in the code that you're trying
to you know understand whatever project
or package or ecosystem
but um i'm not really sure having a
non-technical project will help you for
a gsoft json that will need to be
technical as far as i know
so yeah but it's a great way to get
started at least you know because you've
got to start somewhere and uh
documentation is basically where i
started so i have strong opinions about
that but it's a great way to learn what
code you're going to be writing and what
code you need to be supporting and you
know what codes already out there that
you need to be
using yeah i agree luca you want to add
something there yeah yeah certainly said
that it definitely doesn't hurt and also
if you think like a real project most
problems are not technical are social
like if the project gets stuck it's not
because you don't find the person that
doesn't find the correct line of code to
fix a bug it's because people have
different opinions and there's need for
negotiation and
also
so if your technical non-technical
contribution could be like
push a community of thousands of people
ahead by solving
a conflict then it's fantastic and
also if you think like how people get
noticed and how languages get noticed
like because people are enthused about
it and then write their own blog posts
and share their opinion so
you if your technical contribution is i
wrote this great blog post and now my
company is using julia then i mean
you automatically get quite a lot of
respect so non-technical contributions
are anyway
like the true
heart of open source communities
the
coding is i mean there's a lot of coding
but it's not just coding so it's
definitely a great way to get noticed in
the community and
in general and
get experience and
get contact and start working
yeah luka i love that i actually have a
shirt that's one of my favorite shirts
and it says that there's there's more to
open source than code and that's
actually one of the images that's on the
if you go to the contributor's guide for
the julia on the julia webster which
i'll send um it has that image as well
and i i totally agree i think the the
challenge is that again for google
summer of code it is an inherently
technical
uh program like that the idea is to
write code so
just demonstrating non-technical
contributions might not be enough um if
you don't have some sort of technical
contribution as well but i think the two
combined like that's the super like
that's what we want we want people who
can sort of uh marry those two things
together
so again merch if you can demonstrate
some of the non-technical work like i
know you're doing a bunch of stuff in
the pi data community and on the on the
discord and stuff like that um
demonstrating that sort of work in
conjunction with um
pull requests code contributions is
going to be super helpful
in your in your application
it's a great uh it's a great question um
another one coming in from ashwani uh
better to work on prs related to issues
in an ecosystem or work directly in the
project that i am proposing um
interested saranji any any suggestions
here what you think would be best
um
so
i can speak from my experience so when i
started i was working on a different uh
so there was a ecosystem the youtubing
team and i was uh interested in a topic
on monte carlo in general but
as i started contributing and
interacting uh we figured out that there
is another niche area that would need uh
work so i had moved from the point that
i started to this niche point which
actually became my proposal
so
if if you are clear in your mind what
your proposal is about if you have
spoken with your mentor on that topic
then fine go ahead with that proposal uh
or project and start your prs but if you
are not then it would be nice to start
in the general ecosystem and then try to
narrow down to the topic that you are
you might be interested in and your
mentor might be interested in
no i love that i think that that's
totally right um
big huge plus one uh luca and not
anything you want to
want to add to that
actually you think like she said um
having clarity on what you think your
project is going to look like three
months down the line is what's most
important so if you're really clear what
your project is going to be and what
needs to be done for that you can just
actually start you know flushing out the
house for that itself and uh more often
than not you will be depending on um
other parts of the ecosystems as well
and you might end up needing to
contribute to that as well i mean that's
just part of our process for them
yeah i think it just largely depends on
how much clad you have and if you don't
have much quality as well just get
started and start contributing to
general issues that's a great way to get
noticed and um once you get noticed that
way you can just approach one of the
maintenance of the project and be like
okay i've been contributing this project
a while now what would you like to see
uh you know implemented in this
particular project on this part of the
ecosystem and you know they always have
ideas there's always work to be done in
open source so that'd be a great way to
get started
yeah i really agree and i think the
other piece too and and suranji you
alluded to this is like really making
those ecosystem contributions can
actually be really instrumental in the
success of your actual project like if
you understand the context the full
context of that project
how it's being you know if it's a
package that's being used upstream or
downstream by some other packages like
it can be really important to get that
context and and helping you be
successful uh further down the line in
gsoc so i i do think that making those
contributions to the ecosystem can be
really uh can be really beneficial luca
you want to add anything else to this
one
no nothing particularly that's actually
what i did before getting started i
opened a few prs in the julia intervals
ecosystem where i was working so
nice works
yeah it works
you got three three endorsements here um
lw is asking where you can get my hat um
shoot me a message on slack and i'll
send you a special link but it's uh
yeah i had to have it custom made and
honestly i don't really like it that
much so maybe you want to get a
different hat i have to make a new one
um
but yeah julia hats very cool luca has
the jewel uh which julia shirt is that
luca it's the julia one from last year
oh nice
yeah is it the rapper one oh no it's not
no it's the traditional one with the
logo there
we've got a bunch of cool uh super cool
julia concerts for this year so uh stay
tuned it'll be it'll be exciting
um another question asking about if you
all can reiterate what you did for your
projects i'll send folks you can just
scroll back on youtube really quick see
what
see what we've got and surround you did
and then scroll back to the recent
conversation
and that will save them from having to
say what they did
again but the way to get access to
proposal templates i sent the link in
the chat um we have a proposal template
on the julia website um and then again
surrounded not luca might post their
their application if they still have it
around and they want to in the jsoc
channel on slack or you can reach out to
other students who were
successful previous google summer of
code students so um we don't have any of
them on the website right now but
they're definitely they're definitely
around
um
let's see any other
[Music]
questions
you think it's worth investing time to
learn julia if we want to use it purely
professionally not as an academic in
central europe hardly anyone hires well
this is a more general julia question um
i think just because we already have it
up i think we i think it is definitely
worth learning um a lot of companies um
in the us hiring folks remotely uh so i
would
julia computing for example a bunch of
people all over the world europe uh
india the us
all working on doing julia stuff so it's
it's definitely worth learning a mill if
you're
if if you're interested and will it
change yes of course over time
more folks will use julia and more folks
will
will be hiring for it across across
different ecosystems and industries so
definitely definitely now is the right
time to to learn
um cool let's see if there was other
people asking questions about data
science and machine learning i'm sorry
we will not answer those questions in
this live stream but really good
questions for for discourse for example
um
if you're if you're interested and i i
think
those are those are all the questions
that i've seen and i know we've been
going for
um almost 45 minutes now we'll
we'll wrap it up with just any any sort
of general um high level last minute
suggestions for folks again were just to
give the context were
three days uh three days away from the
deadline
for application so applications close on
tuesday the 19th i don't know what time
of the day um right now it's sunday when
this live stream is being recorded so
we've still got a couple of days um
luca we'll start with you for somebody
who's maybe just stumbled into this live
stream
you know knows what julia is wants to
sort of get from right now to an
application on the 19th any suggestions
um i know we're asking you to
yeah you know a miracle happened but
what would your suggestions be for
somebody who hasn't maybe reached out to
a mentor yet um between now and tuesday
uh yeah uh definitely reach out to the
mentor mentor that's like the core like
communication and be transparent uh be
like very very honest be transparent
don't try to look like smarter than what
you are because
i mean
it's not uh if man the mentor is someone
who has been longer than you in open
source it simply means has been doing
mistakes longer and knows how things go
so you don't need to look like superman
who has all the answers to the universe
but just be honest talk to people get
started
like
it's uh way more impressive if you say
hey i would be interested in these so
here is my idea i tried this and i was
thinking to open the pr than just saying
yeah i would be interested so i could do
this i could do that what do you think i
should do so be active uh better
better sorry than say for whatever
get started open vr's open issues
contact mentors
wonderful and not any any suggestions
for folks in this in these last couple
of days
yeah i'd say um just go for it i mean
just apply for g-shock or
worst case you're not going to get
selected
but then that's fine you can just apply
again next year especially now that it's
open for everyone and i'd say um the
most important piece of advice that i'd
have to anyone applying for gsoc really
is one communicate with your mentor and
to the much more important thing is do
it for the love of open source don't
just do it just because you want to do
g-shock or you want to do something for
the summer or you want that g-shock tab
or anything just do it because you like
open source work and gsoc is a great way
that facilitates that for you and makes
it easier to support whatever side
things you might have going on so yeah
so even if you don't get selected if
you're doing it for law of open source
it doesn't really matter because you'll
just keep contributing anyways you're
bound to get selected if you applied
yeah i love that and i think honestly
luka and not saranji you all are a great
testament to this given like
you're all still active in the open
source community like there definitely
are folks who contribute to g-suck and
then they just disappear off into the
dust um afterwards which is fine i mean
that's what happens but um i think you
all have stuck around and continue to to
contribute in a bunch of different
ecosystems and communities which i think
is awesome and like that's again that's
the point of gsoc is get students
involved in open source keep them in
open source and have them continue to
make those contributions um sranji we'll
close with with any of your suggestions
for students
uh i would say don't chase for
perfection uh try to remember uh so like
this was my role that whatever was the
deadline i would subtract one day from
it and assume that that is the deadline
so just submit your applications as soon
as you can
uh
once you're selected talk to your
mentors be open uh share your problems
take this as a learning journey with its
ups and downs and uh
i am confident you will have a great
experience with gsoc
i love that i i appreciate uh all three
of you for for being part of this
answering questions sharing your
perspective um and and for being part of
the julia community in general so i'm
i'm grateful to all three of you this
was awesome ton of fun thanks for folks
who asked questions um and again if you
if you have questions other thoughts the
jsoc channel on the julia lang slack is
the place to be go there ask questions
and good luck with your applications
we'll
we'll catch you
on slack
take everyone see ya